- On this episode, I bring zero energy,
I answer the questions extremely well,
and I talk about, I don't
know, I don't remember.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep trying
to answer.
(hip hop music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is Episode 25 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Fun fact about number
25, Calvin Pryor wears
number 25 for the Jets.
First round pick, got hurt yesterday.
- [Voiceover] Kartik asks,
"What do you look for
"when hiring creatives?"
- Kartik, great question.
Creatives are really interesting
hire here at VaynerMedia
because in the agency
world, the creative process
is very romantic, by my point of view.
Meaning that, a lot of people
care about winning awards,
a lot of people want to
make movies and TV shows,
and for whatever reason they are
now in the advertising
industry, and they're
caring more about the craft than they are
about the agenda, which is to sell coffee,
to sell whatever this thing is.
To sell phones.
And so to me, what I'm
looking for in creatives
are people that are very
creative, and still want to
make the greatest creative
that they're capable of
but also something that's
grounded in the fact
that we're here to sell stuff.
And if we don't ultimately move product
or inspire people to donate, or make them
aware about a cause,
we are not going to be
fulfilling the duty at hand.
And so I'm looking for
a level of practicality
and a little hint of
2015 data understanding
from my creatives, which
I think is a little bit
of a different spin.
- [Voiceover] Megan asks, "You're like,
"a billionaire, right?
"What do you splurge on?"
- Megan, I'm not even sure if I'm a
100-millionaire.
Maybe with my assets, you know,
VaynerMedia and Wine
Library are doing well,
but I splurge on experiences.
For example, LeBron's first
game back in Cleveland
against my Knicks, as you notice today
I'm wearing orange because I'm starting to
get ready for the basketball season.
You can imagine why.
So, experiences.
You know, vacations with my family,
and definitely things
like LeBron's first game
back in Cleveland, and
they play the Knicks.
AJ's a huge Knicks fan,
more so than even I am.
Let's go with him to that.
Something me and my bro can remember
when we're much older.
It's cool to like, sit
around if you're an old man
and be like, "Remember when we went to
"Kareem's first game back in Milwaukee?
"With the Lakers?"
That's like a fun story.
Those are the kind of
things, I want to spend
money on experiences.
Paying for my friends to go
on trips when I was younger,
when they couldn't afford it.
I splurge on spending time with people
that I care about.
- Hey Gary.
So pre-season hockey is on.
- Pre-season.
- My team, the Washington Capitals.
- Pre-season football still.
- Started a little rough, but
we're looking okay.
Anyway, been following
them since I was a kid,
kinda like you and the Jets.
- Those guys.
- And so I started following
your Snapchat account
about a month and a half ago, and I've
been pretty disappointed with the content
that they've been posting there.
Just wondering, if you
owned a hockey team,
what kind of things would
you do with Snapchat?
- Ah, Kevin, good question, thank you.
Like your background,
also one of my fondest
sports moments was the
1986 Rangers defeating
Langway and Carpenter and
Gardner and those boys
from Washington, so thanks for that win.
You're probably too young
for that, but that was
a big one for me.
You know, I think Snapchat is,
if I owned the Rangers
right now, what I would
be doing with Snapchat
is, recognizing that
it skews young, so I'd try to put out
content that people 13 to 25 would
give a crap about.
So behind the scenes
videos, doing good stories,
I would definitely draw
on top of pictures,
I would take pictures of the players
and draw funny faces on them.
Do little contests, that were very inside
to that community, meaning, knowing it
skews young, take a
screenshot of this snap,
bring it, and we'll let
you skate on the ice.
Things that really engaged the psychology
of the demo on the platform.
And basically I'd rinse and repeat that
everywhere.
40-year-old woman on Pinterest,
what's her psychology on it, she wants
a shop, that's the kind of stuff
I wanna give there.
You know, 13 to 25 year old on Snapchat,
what does he or she
want to see on Snapchat,
silly fun stuff cuz that's
what's going on right now.
Recognizing it's not for my 40 year old
season ticket holder.
So I would play to that psychology.
- [Voiceover] Muscle Company asks,
"How do you generate novel ideas in an
"overpopulated, seemingly stale industry?
"The fitness industry, for example."
- The Muscle Company, I
kinda like saying that.
The Muscle Company, I
always find the best way
to attack an industry that you're in
and is stale, and you want to innovate,
by spending zero time in it.
One little fun fact that
most people don't know
is I spent an awful, excuse me,
an extreme lack of time
within the wine industry
and within the agency industry.
I don't think I've ever been, I've been to
six other agencies in
my life cuz they were
meetings there.
I know nothing about it. I read nothing
about other agencies at Ad Age,
spend no time asking
my senior people about
what they did at other agencies.
When I was in the wine
business, everyone was
like, "You should go check
out this store in Dallas,
"they're doing X," I'm
like, "I don't give a crap."
For me, the way I've
always been innovative
is lack of education, and I'm not joking.
I tend to stay within myself
and what comes natural
and two, I look to other industries.
So if I were you, I
would be paying attention
to what's happening in the food industry
or in the rock-climbing industry or things
completely left field
like hip-hop or sports
or just stuff that has nothing to do with
your industry, because the best way to
stay within the zone and not innovate
is pay attention to everybody else,
because they're doing the same crap too.
- [Voiceover] Joe asks, "With
the NFL in London this week,
"what do you think about sports franchises
"moving to different cities or countries?"
- I think some sports
franchises should go to
very far away places, like
as far from here as possible.
This was episode 25 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Question of the day.
I don't know, what are
the first three websites
you look at every morning?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Fun fact about number
25, Calvin Pryor wears
number 25 for the Jets.
First round pick, got hurt yesterday.
It's funny.
(camera crew laughing)
It's funny that he got hurt.
He did get hurt.
I didn't know what I was gonna say
about 25 but he literally got hurt.
That's unbelievable.
All right.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
(makes gunfire noises)
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social.